yo it's wild 941 man it's the bootleg C
show live in studio right now this dude
he was in town over the weekend decided
to be a good idea to stick around in
Tampa B saying you know I mean the
weather changed yeah we got Omari on
what's up man what's up C what you do
how you been man I've been excellent man
it's been a while yeah it has been a
while last time I saw you there's
actually footage on YouTube of me U
trying to battle you in a dance comp I
was trying to like bust out the little
be cooking dance like back in 2010 like
back in the day it was it was a terrible
look terrible look
but yo everything is going great for you
man congrats on post to be man it's
amazing I'm I'm I'm feeling so blessed
man I'm yeah I remember like talking to
everybody at Atlantic and I you know I'm
a West Coast dude and I remember the
second I heard that song I was like man
if y'all don't push the button on this
record come on now it will be it's
problems it was some incentive you know
yeah it was there like a time though cuz
I felt like the record was out for a
while where you were like you kind of
felt like yo when when are y'all going
to like we got to push the button on
this would we ever at all that you know
I mean it kind of grew a little like it
grew on its own without without the help
of the machine really it did um yeah I
mean I think that what happened was
supposed to happen and that was that you
know a lot of the time when you're an
artist you have to take the power into
into your own hand you know we pay for
the video everything that happened with
post to be you know was pretty much my
team you know so I think that that was
like a a defining moment you know I was
we was put in that circumstance to
really see you know the power of us and
I think that's always great knowing you
know um how things should go and you
know you can't wait on people every you
know what I mean you can't wait on the
machine sometimes sometimes you just got
to go up by yourself uh Ross recently uh
uh got out of jail he was he was locked
up for a while have have you sp have you
you spoke with him seen him since since
he got out how's he doing oh he doing
good I mean um he was like he was he was
really excited about you know the new
music that he's working on
you know uh Ros stay in the studio man
he's he's in good spirits I played him
the new album so um you know hopefully
he promotes it a little bit more than
the last album well you well you know
what to be to be to be quite honest man
you know um which was a good album too
the sex playlist yeah yeah slept on
slept on yeah right right right right
it's okay they waking up they waking up
now but um I I think that uh I think
that you know me being the only type of
artist that's on May group you I think
that you know this establishment of how
things are going is is super cool you
know what I'm saying like of course they
going to have to come to the table
everyone's going to have to come to the
table and play ball a little bit
differently you know mean you got that
smash I'm just saying but but all in all
everyone is so happy with the success of
the record and you know it's a lot of
people rooting me on you know and it's
been a long time in the industry where
I've seen people actually be happy for
another artist yeah and you know it's
crazy cuz I always always talk to people
uh I was actually speaking with uh ill
will ill will from alumni this was uh
before I this was like right right when
post to was like starting to move and he
was like man you know I'm happy for for
oh cuz he's such a good dude like and
that's so cool for people to say that
you know what I mean that's dope man I'm
I'm happy that you know people actually
feel that way a song like post to be you
and Chris Brown have been friends for a
long time right uh Jan eos's you know if
if you've been in La she's been around
for forever um you have to pay Chris
Brown for that feature or is that like
well we don't talk about business but
but just know you know that's my brother
from another you know so so um we we
look out for each other we look out for
each other now Jano when you heard her
verse eatting booties like groceries I
feel like you well well specifically
your song and Kevin Gates has brought
ass e to the Forefront of popular
America in 2015 I I would agree with
that my friend for sure cuz that's like
the question now that's like the so Mar
you eat the
bo man it's crazy right like that's
crazy it's crazy man um so the new album
you got this new song I'm up which we've
actually been playing in mix uh which
which is a really dope record it's got
kid in French on it um what what's uh
what's the album sounding like man to be
to be quite honest I can't wait for
people to hear it you know it's
definitely some some uh some different
sonic waves you know um we got some
great features but it's it's it's a up
from sex playlist um I'm still creating
it right now but um it's it's definitely
you know um I I I would consider the
most important album of the last like 10
years word yeah as far as far as Soul
music goes you know we not going to call
it R&B we're not going to put it in the
Box we're just going to say you know
it's from my soul and it's it's music
from my soul uh have you heard this the
the the Tyrese album I hav but you know
what I want to check that out it's out I
mean it's is it dope have you heard it I
haven't heard it but I just know he's
like you know the saying he's going to
have the number one spot on the
billboard 200 which caught me I was
surprised oh that's dope yeah so I was
just wonder he says he's bringing R&B
back do you think R&B went anywhere no
he says it was dead so no nah no he you
should have told him to listen to the
last album yeah I mean I mean I mean you
might have want to catch that but you
know it's interesting because as as you
know um as as R&B singers you know a lot
of people like to put us in the
background as far as that genre and
class of music but when we speak into
rhythm and blues we still talking about
Melody and to be quite honest with you
every rapper has melody in their songs
now soan if you think of like the guys
that are popping right now like future
and fedy [__] and like they singing
they're singing I mean they're singing
they singing so I mean it's just
interesting the perspective and the
perception of the industry and how
people feel like R like and I feel like
R&B's like had a Resurgence cuz I
remember like as a kid like it was like
genuine and Usher it was like all these
groups jaged Edge and 112 R&B is hard
now and and yo there was a time where
like you know R Kelly started you know
acting like a rapper I'm just saying and
and there wasn't a lot of good R&B I'd
still like to point out I would like an
R&B group to pop right now dop there
hasn't been a hot R&B group in a long
time but I feel like finally there's
like you know Trey Chris yourself Miguel
Frank the weekend it's in a good say
let's keep going yeah it's in a good
place man so you the name of the album
yet are are you are you uh we we playing
around with with the uh with the title
you know what I mean um I don't want to
reveal it just yet okay but um it's
definitely like it's definitely the next
level for for my sound and uh who who
can you give us some features from the
album can you Le leak anything on I I
can't I can't tell you nothing I can't
tell you nothing but I will tell you
that um we know Chris Brown and Jan EO
is gonna be on there when when it's
ready I'm I mean you know sure we do a
listening session Kev And We Vibe out a
a lot of people uh uh you you uh I would
I would like to say I know badw your man
but you know you kind of kept him
relevant for a little bit musically you
know with them hits um if you had to
pick like another rapper right now if
you had your choice to do like a like a
collaborative album with again who who
would it be besides bow well obviously I
mean it would it would it would be
future future man if me and future did
album that stick talk what on that dirty
Sprite too come on I actually had um my
intern drink a cup of dirty sprite
yesterday on the radio we took dirt put
it in I mean liter I mean obviously oh
literal dirt literally dirty sprite yeah
not we didn't get the lean what what
what did that taste like I don't know he
he was sick all night it
would anyway well yo man uh you're G to
be back on Love & Hip Hop yes season two
and I would like to congratulate you cuz
a lot of people who do that make that
move I'm just saying you've like you're
like revolutionizing I'm just saying
like that whole you know trend of people
who do that it's usually it's usually
you know you're thriving I'm just saying
hold yourself down don't don't look
crazy okay don't be on TV acting crazy
just to get you know I'm just saying it
I mean you know the check ain't that big
I'm just saying that's what it is man
you know if you want to get to the bands
you got to act right Omar yo let's get
into the new record right now word up
your boy om Aran check it out I'm Up
featuring French Montana kidy let's
go